Speaker 1: Let's you know, last week we tried
to check in with Eric from Cancun, and he
wasn't there.
So I'm going to try once more, Eric from Cancun.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 4: They it's sunny right now.
And the thing I want to tell you last week
is what you think of traditions,
Speaker 1: what do I think of traditions?
I am not in favor of traditions only for traditions
sake.
I don't find a virtue in traditions in principle,
but I have no problem with specific traditions
that are meaningful to people.
Speaker 4: And that's exactly where they want
to tell you, because tradition started to
commemorate the people that did things for
us, to celebrate, to improve our lives.
And I still like traditions like giving gifts,
things, birthdays st Valentine's in holiday
winters.
He then.
I think that conservatives would be very upset
or worried that the Liberals want to get rid
of those traditions.
But I think that we're not really getting
rid of them.
Only changing the way we do.
For example, in Halloween, I need cosmetics
for temperatures.
So and I think we should rethink about some
traditions, like forcing women to stay in
the kitchen, ignoring the opinion of children
and killing animals who pretend to be brave
and strong instead of taming the beast like
a real men.
Also, like Lieutenant Dan, the one to die
in Vietnam because his ancestors died.
In other words, if you saw forest gump.
Speaker 1: Yes, be a fantastic movie.
Speaker 4: And and then you remember, well,
the other thing I was going to say, oh, I
remember now, if you saw those who remembered
just you see Fiddler on the Roof, the first
song is called Tradition, and there's a farmer
called Fabian who says that in an attempt
to capture the essence of how to pray, how
to sleep, how to eat, to wear their yarmulke,
to pray, to God.
And here's the most important part.
He says, when he is going to tell us how this
tradition started, he says at no.
But leans on tradition and thanks to their
traditions, they know what God expect them
to do.
Speaker 1: Well, Eric, you know, you've touched
in such a short amount of time on the weather,
religion, philosophy, film.
I can't thank you enough for the wide ranging
phone call.
Speaker 4: And one to tell me two things before
we cut and for two more
Speaker 1: things, oh my goodness.
Speaker 4: So they come in about an I recall,
and they say I care about cartoonish boys.
Maybe if I do my impersonation of Mario, like,
is it me, Mario?
Who can anyone tell Nintendo to give me money
for college?
I cultural come to work as a new boy or
Speaker 1: Eric from Cancun.
Thank you so much for the call.
You've set it all in.
On that note, we are going to have to go.